omnipotent once
geolocator i assume you mean geoguesser
geolocator um probably not tonight
there's a lot of people still
challenging
including john davis also i barely i
should i should give i barely know
the rules who's a sub but probably
forgot to
update their sub name okay let's fight
john
okay playing john um
man last time i played john actually so
this is funny i i just edited the
youtube video
i'll put out tomorrow or i played knight
c3 against jon
i think i'll play knight c3 again and
we'll see if jon has learned his lesson
maybe this will be a part two to the
youtube video
and john already deep in thought
because john knows what's coming i think
in in the last game john played g6
e4 c5 and we we went into some
fun fun knight c3 sicilian
oh e6 wait john doesn't play a french
does shawn play a french no he does not
okay let's let's test john i'm gonna
play d4 and then e4
i play d4 to avoid sicilian
i guess c5 is maybe still possible
okay french time
definitely have not played this against
jon yet
okay c5 let's take the knight f3
oh what is this john confusing me
queen takes there's this crazy move but
then bishop b5
thank you slime slime mold is a thing
gifting a sub to elsid barrett
thanks so much
yeah there's gonna be there's gonna be
some nice pins in this position
i'm probably already like winning a pawn
i think
i mean this is an attempt but then this
oh this is pinned though
so maybe i can i can play this oh
there's a cool line
if knight c6 i take it i lose a queen oh
he's not going into it
i was gonna say i would lose a queen but
then promote
because discover check it's not
happening
hmm if i played d6
d6 is a move i want to play but it
doesn't quite work
let's uh probably queenside castle
get the battery on the d file ambient
chess
thanks for the 100 bits
was that the mouse slip that had to be a
mouse slip right
john i don't know if you're watching
i'll give you a take back if that was a
mouse slip
but maybe it wasn't and this might be a
john move
like he just wants to attack me
but okay free bishop free bishop
my attack is quicker
tough game very tough that was just an
opening gone wrong
like john i think is is pretty well
prepared in like a lot of
a lot of like main lines but like c3 is
it's a nice way to like throw people off
not sure if a5 was an alpha zero move
not sure what alpha zero would have done
probably would not have gotten into to
this position
in the first place
yeah so the bishop's trapped ooh
so john john continuing his plan
interesting
looking for meat okay i think this
is this is reasonable
because queen d8 is coming if
this is made into that twitch baby ooh
twitch baby
oh is that what okay so bank stuffman
subbed for eight months
so i guess when you subbed for nine
months does that make you a twitch baby
huh yeah queen d8
vamanos winning
like forcing a queen trade winning the
rook
a very unfortunate game for john
there are three legal moves
dead man welcome back long time no see
dead man
subbing for 22 months
there's another username called
it's dead man something but
it's not the real dead man
welcome back yeah so
and john probably suffering here again
okay
just a couple legal moves
i'm hoping to construct some kind of
mate is jean gonna play oh
john to resign i mean a3 would have been
some alpha zero attempt
i was gonna say i wanted to construct
some mate like this
would be beautiful yeah tough game
i don't know john do i put that on
youtube as a sequel
a knight c3 what can i recommend against
knight c3
let's give some instruction i mean
because
this position like you really have to
know what you're doing
which would basically mean that you have
to know what to do in the french
which is possible i think bishop b4 and
knight f6 are the two main moves
against light c3 i can recommend d5
and then um
it's hard for white to actually trick
black into
[Music]
some opening like okay if d4 then it's
kind of a
varisav or jobava london which you
should be prepared against anyway
and then i think the main move here is
e4
but this i think is a good line for
black like d4 and then this
and then
yeah bishop d6 or f6
it is worth maybe taking the time to
study
but who is john galt john what
who is john john galt i don't know who
john galt is